a US Navy aircraft carrier in Iceland Oh
captain his eyes have to not like he's
in US Navy aircraft ah nice
so I Disney movie yes where the vehicles
come talk yeah need be sing a beautiful
song yeah so I captain on a US Navy
aircraft carrier is being fired for
creating too much panic on his ship
because of the virus
what is this the one where they want to
dock somewhere else or what I've done
every day it's grim on the intercom or
some [ __ ] like [ __ ] so he's getting
Intel that there is there is an outbreak
on a ship right and there's about four
thousand people on the ship those things
are like just to put in perspective a
lot of more like a mile or two long a
mile long straight up [ __ ] City yes
like a mile or two long I'll be able to
[ __ ] race on that thing those things
are stripped yeah those things are they
could be a mile or two miles long
the all the people are like cheering
Ching like base excluding him for
leaving he's trying to do the right
thing for his people
yeah he's worried about his semen and he
was just trying to do what he thought
was right and he's broke he's the
captain yeah and he I guess broke he's
in charge of the entire vehicle which
broke protocol based on what his
commander theme was was a better what
what is the better thing was to not do
what he did and what he did was send out
a memo
I guess via email and he copied copied
too many people in the memo so it's just
the news went out to too many different
people and he eventually got to news
outlets cuz they afford it
yeah he forwarded it like so so he see
see too many people only problem I could
message yourself he wanted to tell a lot
of people I I think he was just trying
to tell the people he cared about or
like what he thought was a reasonable
amount I guess and then based on four
again they start pouring it but it was
like tip top secret [ __ ] yes yeah and so
the official thing would be the
tattletale was that what it does it
undermines the efforts in the chain of
commands and their efforts to address
this problem creates a panic and there
you know the idea of not creating panic
was kind of like what the whole
government Oh what I heard was because
he sounded an alarm or whatever he
basically put it out for the ship
basically because there was an outbreak
and they didn't want to say anything and
they're just gonna let people basic
continue working on the ship like
normally but he was afraid of everyone
catching it so he broke protocol and
announced it to everyone so they can
either find safety or have to go through
safety right and then boarding
quarantine the guys that were yes it's
about 3,000 people are gonna be taken
off the ship to be quarantined yeah I
got that waft is gonna be in a the
aircraft carriers gonna be in active
pretty much they're docked in Guam right
now yeah oh it's about 5,000 people
3,000 of them are gonna be taken off the
ship I guess the the higher
didn't want that they want them to
continue to keep going and then they
would have all got like the virus or
something yeah yeah I guess it was
worried and he was worried about his
crew and every one of the board for
their safety so that's why he yeah he's
just been a good dad you know he's just
trying to be a good you know father
figure to everyone on and it's under his
command so yeah I think he was just
doing what he thought was right sounds
like a plot to every like movie that has
war in it you know yeah it's like you
gotta follow the chain of command it's
like no I gotta look out for my people
and then once my goes rogue and they're
like well you're you're kicked off team
buddy they're gonna make a movie about
this guy yeah you know how many lives he
saved
dude there's gonna be a saving captain
Ryan Captain Navy secretary commas moly
saving captain boldly no no captain Bret
Crozier that's better saving captain
Crozier croucher that's the public's
consensus on it do they agree with them
or like or the rest of the world they
agree with them or they think that's
[ __ ] up for breaking chain of command
I don't know what do you guys think I
don't think the public ever cares about
I amend if I was if I want if I was on a
boat I would want my captain as he see
me and say guess what there's a sick
[ __ ] here yeah watch out for
[ __ ] private James I think so on
Twitter everyone was like this is dope
like congrat congratulating him and then
also the UH there was because it was one
guy in Trump's command that I figure out
what he did he like killed hello people
are like not like in texture but like in
war in a bad way or he was like accused
of rape and like all these things where
he does something really bad and he got
pardoned I remember he committed a crime
and got pardoned and then it was a great
bat pie that you shouldn't get pardoned
for it was Trump like is that all you
did that's it yeah pardon and then so
you got part of the military guys so
another another military guy got
pardoned from his criminal activity and
then this guy got fired so this guy this
guy got fun but it's
not the same is it the same people that
that made yeah yeah or is it just like
this is how weird the military in the
laws that's hiring a fine whatever I'm
not too sure or partying about you mean
in terms of reference that both of them
were getting fired multiple getting
reprimanded but Trump intervened with
one of them right to two parts on
Twitter they just tell you the headline
damn ball I'm working with is the video
and it seems like semen every time you
say yeah I can I feel that pong right
before you say you're like that I mean
when you say come it's not semen no one
says semen you know but in this case I
want to see semen sale your sellers
right yeah
so a captain of the name is actually
really high captain and Navy is like a
colonel I guess like on the land branch
so they're right below Admiral so it's
like a really high rank so I don't know
if he's like so how up that Jena command
do they start teaching you how to make
like fried chicken fight all for colonel
it'll perfect it until anything about
the ranking start with if you're an
officer they feel not to desert know
like the basic like boot camp boy then
your recruit you're not even recruits
not even anything so after you finish
boot camp then you become a private
private first and it goes private first
class just the Marine Corp has an army
slightly different and then it from
private first class you go to Lance
Corporal you go to corporal then you go
- Sarge it and you go Staff Sergeant
then you go to gunnery sergeant or the
armory at sergeant first class and then
you go to like Master Sergeant and you
go to like a sergeant that's a lot of
yeah you write that down better than
your officer or that's it you're at the
top of the enlisted branch it's almost
like it's almost like like blue-collar
worker and then like white-collar worker
so then at the in after that then it's
officer levels like the what was once
after that and like captain or what
then this'll goes second lieutenant
first lieutenant captain major
lieutenant colonel colonel and in
general and then every single star of
the job
there's so many levels and this like
each level have their own squad like
their own crew like one squad I'm
thinking of just ancient military right
because like the Mongols what they did
is like they had a team of ten yeah and
within that team of ten to be like one
captain of that ten but then ten tenths
make a team of like a hundred that's
exactly how its organized yeah like
let's say depending on like if what
branch and like what they do but like
let's say if you have a fire team about
three or four people there's probably
gonna be a bunch of privates or whatever
and you have a Lance Corporal in charge
of that then you have three lance
corporals and then you might have like a
squad leader that might be a corporal
and it's what that might be like eleven
or twelve people that's considered a
squad then three or four of those guys
create a platoon and so usually have a
platoon sergeants or they have this like
twenty four thirty that's in charge of
like three or four corporals who's in
charge of that so then then platoons
makeup like a battalion battalion make
up a division so it's very highly
organized yeah so if things need to get
passed quickly like news will travel
fast orders travels extremely fast it's
extremely organized it's just like that
yeah yeah yeah that's why the chain of
command is so important right because
once you break any wearing that like
chain it [ __ ] that doesn't work as well
yeah and that's why they have like top
secret confidential stuff like
need-to-know basis because like if
communication reaches people before it's
packaged in the right way it might
create havoc
that's because ultimately the most
important goal is mission accomplishment
so I don't know but it's also but then
the second one the second priority is
also troop welfare so if the priorities
are kind of conflicting it's like I can
see why there's like both sides on this
so you being in the military I come from
the military what do you think of this
well I don't know the details that's a
pain like I don't know I don't know what
the details are and then I know this
captain's in charge of a lot of people
like four or five thousand people that's
crazy it's like in charge of an entire
city just from this story though it
sounds like it was an accident right
wasn't even like I know you were like oh
how to use the email Kitty see but you
also can't be making accidents out
you know because everyone's cheering
them on like yeah he did the right thing
but just the way that you were saying it
sounds like I had too many people with
me I read it verbatim so assuming that
he sent it off to family members to baby
baby this was everyone's cousin Batum he
said the captain copied too many people
on the memo which was leaked to a
California newspaper and quickly spread
to many news I could see it in the
military sense because that when the
media gets it then if we are at war or
whatever or they're doing a mission and
they're not supposed to be in a certain
place then you know other governments
are gonna know about it so because
that's why the Spanish flu is called a
Spanish flu is because that [ __ ] was
erupting in the US and I think in
Austria Germany or wherever the world
was happening but Spain wasn't really a
part of the world war at the time so
when they started getting the flu their
media wasn't censoring it so back then
all the powers that were fighting each
other they were losing soldiers out in
the battlefield more from the flu than
from bullets so they were afraid that if
they seemed weak like they don't want to
show that their soldiers were sick or
weak or anything so they didn't let
their media like reporting ping yeah so
the American media and the German media
out there didn't say [ __ ] and that's why
the Spanish you know they said it so
they thought everyone thought that it
came from Spain yeah that's the biggest
argument everyone's having right now
they're like yeah you know blow about
the Spanish flu because people are like
about the the China mahadji's virus
right I don't know like well that's
where I came from and people are like
just like the Spanish flu and then the
other side is like bashful you didn't
come from Spain and came to America
first why don't we call it the American
flu so these incidents
you know caused brought brought up
another idea or another like criticism
of how if this isn't it happened then
does that affect other captains from
wanting to do the right thing if an
outbreak happens on their ship or maybe
it's just the right thing is don't miss
copy people
maybe I don't know what the actual
contacted to his grandma and a grandma
[ __ ] said to do like because maybe
email was perfectly fine it's just the
people he copied on it you know so I
don't even know but also I got a I think
there should be more digging because
from everything that because I went kind
of deep into that thread
nothing was talking about email it was
more talking about him alarming the
people on the ship was in an actual so
maybe but basically the the higher-ups
were like don't tell the people on the
ship because they're trying to do
whatever they wanted but he was like
they're gonna get sick and he's gonna
spread wild if I don't say anything he
sent that email to everybody that's what
I'm guessing if it wasn't email it was
100% confirmed that there was somebody
on the ship that had coronavirus yeah
more than 100 sailors on the ship have
tested positive for the bars but none is
Hospital oh my god yeah but they didn't
want to like they don't want to say that
he was like I want to protect my my my
people and he was I'm did the right
thing and save them what do you guys
think right thing or how do you do the
right thing right if maybe the military
higher-ups were like well there's a
safer way to do this and if we don't
tell them now we can do it in a way that
people don't panic and then maybe it
won't spread as much you know like I
don't I don't know what the big plan was
yeah could you say that was a bad idea
it's like the higher up you go the
bigger the plans don't want somebody
secrets up there the more they need to
orchestrate things right so for like
let's say whoever his boss is probably
the Admiral of some sort if he is like
okay cool
I know we have 12 aircraft carriers and
I'm creating a solution for 12 of them
right and then you have one aircraft
carrier just going rogue and figuring
out whatever the hell they do that can
destroy the plan for all 12 when there
are people working on solutions for also
like I get from one person's point of
view go these are my people but then
your boss is like I know about all of
you guys are my people it's like it's is
this hard to know with like not enough
information like what's going on
[Music]
[Music]